i want to hear proposition
let's wind the clocks back a year
these cops and lawyers wouldn't dare
cross any of you
i mean
what happened your balls drop off
you see a guy like me
freak
a guy like me look listen
i know why you choose to have your
little
group therapy sessions in broad daylight
i know why you're afraid to go out at
night
the batman
see batman has shown gotham your true
colors unfortunately
dan
he's just the beginning
and as for uh the
television's
so-called plan
batman has no jurisdiction he'll find
him and make him squeal
i know the squealers when i see them and
what do you propose
it's simple we uh kill the batman
if it's so simple why haven't you done
it already if you're good at something
never do it for free
how much you will
have
you're crazy i'm not
no i'm not
if we don't deal with this now
soon
little uh gamble here won't be able to
get a nickel for his grandma
enough from the clown
let's not blow
this out of proportion
you think you can steal from us and just
walk away yeah i'm putting the word out
500 grand for this clown dead a million
alive so i can teach him some manners
first
all right so listen why don't you give
me a call when you want to start taking
things a little more seriously here's my
card
we've just seen the joker try and
negotiate with the mob so let's explain
the game theory
there are a couple of interesting
quotations in the scene
one is when the joker explains that he's
going to kill the batman the mob asks
him how much he wants
and the joker explained he wants half of
all their profits
the mob thinks this is a pretty funny
and ridiculous offer
but
they can't just simply reject him
because the other element of the scene
is that time is of the essence the joker
explains that if they don't deal with
the problem soon
that gamble or anyone else won't have
any money to spend at all
so the game has three components
one is the joker and the mob are
bargaining over a share of the profits
in return for the joker taking care of
batman
another part is if they don't agree if
they can't come to an agreement then
slowly they're going to lose their
entire criminal operation
batman and law enforcement are actually
gaining ground
and therefore the mob is going to end if
they don't come to an agreement
and this is the important part that time
is of the essence day by day the batman
harvey dent everyone else is getting
stronger and the mob is getting weaker
so these three elements define
an alternating ultimatum game where the
mob makes a proposal the joker can
easily reject it or accept it
he can then come back with a counter
offer and so on and each time they make
a proposal
there's a discount value where day by
day the profits are shrinking
this is often depicted
by a tree diagram that continues between
the mob and the joker and so on
in this video i'm not going to explain
how we get to the solution i've linked
to
a great video by william spaniel in game
theory 101 or you can read some links
that i put in the description
but when you have a scene where you have
a discount value and you have several
alternating offers
it ends up being that the fair solution
is actually about a 50 50 split to each
and this is interesting because the mob
actually does agree to give the joker
half of the profits
it only turns out
that the joker has other plans for his
share of the money
thank you for watching
please subscribe to my youtube channel i
make videos on math and game theory
you can also check me out at my blog
mind your decisions or follow me on
twitter at preshtalwalker and get my
books on amazon